et on aurait pu l'éviter si vous n'aviez
pas joué à des jeux que vous demandez
aux présentes
je plaisante en fait c'est drôle est ce
que c'est si dur de comprendre qu'on
avait besoin de sa retenue ce n'est
peut-être pas le moment d'en parler je
voulais dire c'est réglé alors vous
rouler en boule à chaque fois que
quelqu'un grogne seulement quand j'ai
créé un robot de la nasa
on était loin du but est-ce qu'on avait
une interface vous avez bien fait
quelque chose et vous l'avez fait ici
les avengers ne devait pas être comme le
sheed vous rappeler que j'ai trimballé
une ogive nucléaire dans un trou de ver
non ça me revient sauver new york
première nouvelle vous avez oublié une
armée d'ennemis extraterrestres nous a
attaqués par un trou dans l'espace et on
se trouvait sans mettre ou pas on est
les avengers
on peut appréhender des trafiquants
d'armes les doigts d'en aimer ce type de
menace c'est quitte ou double comment
vous espérez l'affronter ensemble